[Music]
all right let's go down the street here
in Nashville and talk to Elijah what's
up
Elijah hey Dr John I really appreciate
you having me you got it man what's
going on
dude hey so I got married about three
weekends ago awesome I've got congrats
man thank you I got a wonderful wife um
she's everything I could ask for what I
wanted to ask about to today was was
just kind of a roadmap to one obviously
how do I not mess this up and two one of
the things we've talked about is let's
make this the best marriage of all time
and and she's on board with me on that
we we see eye to eye on on pretty much
everything I can think of um so and I've
looked we've had premarital counseling
um I feel like we're doing the right
things but I just I just really want to
make sure that that we're doing the
right things that we need to do people
talk about putting in the work on
marriage and they don't really go past
that and explain really what that means
so just a roadmap for how we make this
the best marriage that we can dude I
love that question
and it's a disastrous goal can I can I
blow up your whole model for this yeah
you can you can blow it up all
right
100% do not seek to have the best
marriage of all time that's too much
pressure to put on both you and your
wife and your marriage that's not the
goal
okay the goal is
to ask every single day how can I love
you
today yeah and we're going to put in
some pictures of what that looks like
make no mistake you will mess this up go
ahead and Release Yourself from that
you'll mess it up you know what she will
too yeah and then y'all will both try to
fix it and work on it and you'll both
mess it up okay yeah so I'll give you a
couple things off top of my head that um
I wish I had known when I started also
knowing I wouldn't have done any of it
right
um I I saw this recently that before the
internet we thought that people made
dumb decisions because they didn't have
the
information now we know that is not true
right yeah people have the info and they
continue to make dumb decisions so I'm
Gonna Fill A couple things up here uh
fill you in with a couple things and um
kind of go from there okay that that
sounds great all right so the first
thing
is I want you to not try to over
intellectualize this yeah I want y'all
to make a habit a practice a daily
morning practice a daily evening
practice and then a little more of an
intensive weekly practice and then a
real intensive annual practice and that
is simply not trying to guess how she
wants to be loved yeah not try to guess
how she wants to be kept
safe not try to guess what she needs
from you or but get in a regular rhythm
of
asking yeah and the quicker you can
demystify the Hollywood bull crap that
is you're supposed to read her mind and
she's supposed to read your mind and
that's what romance is the quicker you
can melt that nonsense and be honest
with each other and begin to think of it
this way over time I'm going to teach
her how I best feel loved and vice versa
and by the way knowing every five to 10
years you're going to change and so is
she yeah actually maybe every month or
two right yeah but so what we're doing
is we're building a framework we're not
coming up with a bunch of
answers so we're going to build a
framework where every day I'm gonna ask
you hey what's the best way I can love
you today what's your picture of today
look like and she might say I don't know
what kind of question is that that means
her dad her dad never asked that
question she never saw her dad asked her
mom that question she might not even
know cool we're gonna figure that out
and vice versa how can I love you today
and you'll be like uh I don't know
you'll make out over time you'll you'll
come up up with I really need just to
sleep tonight or I really need to Let's
I just need to go to something crazy can
we just go out and I know we can't
afford it I know it's whatever queen go
out like right so we're going to slowly
begin to practice that but if she knows
you're going to ask that question every
morning and every evening and every
Sunday night you're going to get
together and go over the calendar for
the week and go over your budget for the
week dude you're building a marriage
that is so resilient that when something
happens and a whole bunch of things will
happen Elijah y just got to trust me on
this yeah both of your parents if if if
the world works out the way it's
supposed to You'll bury all four
parents yeah you'll bury all of your
grandparents one of you will find
yourself super into somebody else you
work with or somebody else at church or
somebody else in your neighborhood and
you'll have to F claw your way
back one of you will hurt the other
person you'll have parenting difference
these things will happen this is
marriage y okay yeah but if every every
day how can I love you today yeah yeah
that's good okay that's number one
number two be very clear about asking
your wife what does safety look like to
you you sound like a guy that's into
like how do I protect and provide right
that kind of stuff yep yep Jiu-Jitsu
working out yeah there you
go when my wife and I were dating this
is going to shock you I'm G blow your
mind I was a hotthead a real hotthead
dude and then when I got into MMA and it
was less sport when I got into it it was
more just like practice was sparring and
like some situps and then more sparring
um yep going hard I thought protecting
my wife was getting in a fight all the
time and what I came to realize was I
made her feel less safe on a daily basis
yeah because she didn't know if I was
GNA pop off at a grocery store she was
the one that said John if you get into
some altercation in a restaurant because
somebody looked at me wrong and you tell
yourself you're protecting me and his
buddy hit you on the head with a
bottle I'm left alone with two crazed
guys you have not protected me and so I
learned with my wife that the greatest
way I could protect her was to get her
out of situations to
leave yeah and so for me courage was not
getting in the middle of a situation
courage for me was sucking up my ego and
pride and getting my wife to a safe
place bringing her
home yeah that's good does that make
sense I yeah I can definitely I can
definitely lean towards during the first
like that guy look at you I'm gonna go
get him I'm gonna I'm gonna ask him hey
what are you looking at and say yeah
that's good and your wife will probably
say uh do you think I'm beautiful and
you'll go yeah and she'll go he does too
get over yourself right and you'll go oh
yeah right so um but that's asking the
question hey when does this make you
feel safe and there's other times um I
used to joke my wife's a Texas feminist
she'd be like women should be paid all
this stuff right that's all true and
then she would be like you need to go
hit that
dude I don't know what to do but so
there there is times that that's like
you know what I mean but that's not for
this show here's the deal communication
and asking what what to do right you
know what makes her feel safe yep what
does intimacy feel like what does sex
like
like what what makes you feel loved yeah
what makes you feel all hot and bothered
what makes you just want to get it on
like
not you going oh I know it's going to be
because that's the way you're you feel
or that's what you way you saw it in
some movies some sometimes like let her
dictate that and hopefully vice versa
that you open up a dialogue that she can
ask you that stuff um and that leads to
what does being loving look
like ask that question because I thought
being
loving probably the first 15 years was
making money getting a bunch of titles
getting invited to stuff getting getting
things autographed for my
wife
um running around in the middle of the
night with police officers and Fighters
so that I could look like I was living
them life that I really wasn't living I
wasn't in the CIA even though I was like
yeah bro I watch the shows all like all
that was me trying to love my wife come
to find out she just wanted me and I
didn't have a psychology for
that because my only value was found in
utility what can I
do and she was like a I'm smarter than
you B at the time I make the same amount
of money as you about um will you just
hold my hand and watch a sunset with me
and drink some
coffee yeah right and by the way that's
changed there's a season when you need
to go to work there's a season when like
you got to write a book and there's a
season when kids are born and need some
help like but it changes over time but
what does loving look
like yeah that's good I'm I'm gearing up
for a time where I'm going to have to
have to work really hard for about two
to three years for my career and getting
that started perfect and and knowing
knowing that communication is going to
be you know the biggest thing asking how
can I love you how can I make you feel
safe those questions that's I'm sure
that's gonna be really important that
time and I here's a a magic question for
every marriage I think every person
that's married or about to be married
should ask this question what do we want
our home to feel
like yeah and then let's reverse
engineer that and in at my house I
wanted it full of laughter wanted it to
feel warm when I walked in and so we had
to figure that out well John if you want
the house to feel warm I need you to put
your dishes up the night
before yep John I need you to help make
the bed I need you to help with the kids
in the morning and so then when you get
home ah right awesome let's do that
relax yeah U and here's a couple of
other things that are marriage
adjacent you take care of
you all the way around not just lifting
weights and going to jiu-jitsu make sure
you got a group of men that you talk to
on the
regular that you tell the stuff that
makes you scared dude I'm scared about
like my
job yeah I am like this woman that I
work with she thinks I'm hilarious and
like I'm kind of starting to like think
up a joke that I can tell her when I get
to work like dude and you got to have
people that you talk to yeah okay yeah
that's good um and the third like go see
a counselor man if you're about to gear
up and go get it get yourself a coach
get yourself a counselor that you can so
that way you don't use your wife as a
trash can over the next 3 years mhm that
she only gets you when you're exhausted
and you're not gonna believe what
happened today right Y and then here's
the last one hold all of this with a
really open
hand the greatest quote I've ever heard
about marriage was from EST Perell when
she said most adults have four or five
great passionate loves in their
adulthood and if they work really hard
it can be with the same person M I've
been married for 21 and A2 years I'm a
radically different person than I was 5
years ago
unrecognizable I am radically different
from the guy I was 10 years ago
literally
unrecognizable and the guy that got
married when he was 24 I even that dude
geez that guy needs to be taken out
behind the Woodshed and just beat right
and so I tell you she's gonna change and
so are
you and that's not the problem that's
the beauty
yeah that's good so if you hold her to a
list of you said you believe in
this dude the greatest thing is changing
our beliefs it's one of my favorite
things in the world to do that's why I
read books why I listen to podcasts
that's why I have interviews that's why
I travel the country Oh I thought I
believed this I thought something
different you and your wife need to be
really secure on your values and hold
your beliefs super super lightly so me
and my wife share some values dignity
and resp respect no matter
what curiosity over
everything um uh
Hospitality right so if she comes in and
goes hey I don't think I believe X
anymore I believe y
now then our value is not you will
believe exactly like me it is curiosity
and dignity whoa dude that sounds wild
tell me about that right yeah that's
different than you can't tell our kids
that our kids are gonna be fine you see
what I'm saying so maybe a fun like
month do this brother have a one- Monon
anniversary she she'll never see it
coming have a one-month anniversary and
uh take her out and have something
really nice where y'all can write down
your values who are we going to be and
make sure you talk through I know our
beliefs are going to change you're going
to read a book you're going to have an
experience you're going to get fired I'm
going to get fired we're going to have
changes in what we believe that's the
beauty of our life the only people who
can't figure that crap out are
politicians Cheez Louise we're going to
get new information cool that's awesome
what are our values going to be who are
we going to
be and let's ink those in right now and
then let's hold some beliefs really
Loosely I'm going to send you um all of
the questions for humans cards both
decks for couples and the Christmas one
that is probably going to be sold out by
the time the show comes out and I'm
going to send you a couple other
questions for humans decks and building
an unanxious life I want youall to read
that book together and just build a road
map in your house as yall are you're
saying okay the next 3 years I'm going
to be grinding it in my job which is
Amazing by the way um I've had multiple
two or three or four years stin when I'm
grinding it grinding at work um use that
as a road map how are we both going to
be whole in our house it's gonna be
awesome I'm proud of you man great
questions to be asking I waited till
you're 15 to ask these questions so dude
you're way ahead of the game take care
good man
he